well you can call kevin o'leary the
simon cowell of canada he's heard worse
but when this dragon invited e.t canada
inside his newest den
i found out this fire-breathing tv host
is
actually a breath of fresh air
hello kim welcome to fantasy condo
thank you
you've been here for what four days well
i've only stayed here
a few nights to be truthful well the
truth here is this guy is
busy we kind of lost count after five tv
shows
an investment company and now a memoir
if a man could give birth it would be a
book because it took me
a very long time to get this done two
years
i think a lot of women would contest
that i know i've heard that
you're not the first one to say that but
i believe it's hard where did it come
out of though
well you know a lot of people have a lot
of opinions about you
yeah i get that i don't i don't let that
get in the way of going forward you look
like a dork
walking around with these poles i get so
much flack and marine dragon and all
that stuff
i'm not the mean dragon i'm the only one
that tells the truth now kevin lets his
softer side show through just a little
when showing off his den of prized
possessions
my most coveted piece is this les paul
signed by les paul is a beautiful
instrument i still play it
he's not joking on his walls hang
original negatives of jim morrison
janice joplin and jimi hendrix
an ancient mosaic and a chagall print
titled greed
that was very appropriate because i'm
always talking about money these are
where i keep my real classics so here's
a
a 1990 chateau la tour now that is
nectar
from the nipple of aphrodite how much
does a bottle of wine like that cost
i bought this back then for about
three hundred dollars and it would trade
now for about five thousand